This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In all our lives, there are moments when the ground starts to shake beneath us, when our world becomes destabilized and everything changes. These moments can feel disorienting, upsetting, but they can also allow us to see things in new ways. Over the past year, all of us have had our own ground shaking moments. What can we do all these months into the COVID-19 pandemic to reframe our challenges,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在我们的一生中，总有一些时刻，脚下的土地开始震颤，世界变得动荡不安，一切都发生了改变。这些时刻可能会让人感到迷失、沮丧，但它们也能让我们以新的方式看待事物。在过去的一年里，我们所有人都经历过这种脚下震颤的时刻。在新冠疫情持续这么久之后，我们能做些什么来重新审视我们的挑战，
to use disruption as a source of reinvention? Every August, we bring you a series called You 2.0. It's about approaching the chaos of our lives with wisdom. Over the next month, we look at how to cultivate more empathy in our intermaturelationships. So your spouse is late, your spouse does something inconsiderate, you have a lot of control over how that behavior affects you. How to reinterpret the past by understanding the nature of memory? The question is which reconstructed memories are more accurate, and can you learn to monitor
利用这种破坏作为重塑自我的源泉？每年八月，我们都会为您带来名为“你 2.0”的系列节目。它旨在教我们如何以智慧应对生活的混乱。在接下来的一个月里，我们将探讨如何在人际关系中培养更多的同理心。比如你的配偶迟到了，或者做了些欠考虑的事，你其实很大程度上可以控制这种行为对你的影响。如何通过理解记忆的本质来重新诠释过去？问题在于，哪些重构的记忆更准确，你是否能学会监控
that process? And I think people can. And how to grow from our mistakes. Regret is actually a very hopeful emotion. It's something that is helping us learn from our mistakes and do better in the future. Today, we begin our series with a simple but essential ingredient in life that we all crave.
那个过程？我认为人们是可以做到的。以及如何从错误中成长。遗憾实际上是一种充满希望的情绪。它能帮助我们从错误中学习，并在未来做得更好。今天，我们以生活中一个简单却至关重要的要素开启我们的系列节目，这是我们每个人都渴望的东西。
Purpose is an ancient concept. We, as a species, have been grappling with this concept forever. How cultivating a sense of purpose can help us weather life's biggest storms. This week, on Hidden Brain. Cornell University Psychologist Anthony Barrow has spent much of his career studying what it means to have a sense of purpose. He has examined how we can cultivate purpose and how having a sense of purpose can transform our lives. Tony Barrow, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Tony, I want to play you a short clip from the 1967 movie The Graduate. In this scene, a young Dustin Hoffman plays Benjamin Braddock. He's a fresh out of college
目标是一个古老的概念。作为一个物种，我们一直在与这个概念搏斗。培养目标感如何能帮助我们度过人生最大的风暴。本周，在《隐藏的大脑》中。康奈尔大学心理学家安东尼·巴罗（Anthony Barrow）职业生涯的大部分时间都在研究拥有目标感意味着什么。他研究了我们如何培养目标感，以及拥有目标感如何改变我们的生活。托尼·巴罗，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你的邀请。托尼，我想给你播放一段 1967 年电影《毕业生》的短片。在这场戏中，年轻的达斯汀·霍夫曼饰演本杰明·布拉多克。他刚大学毕业，
lounging in his parents pool when his dad confronts him. Ben, what are you doing? Well, I would say that I'm just drifting here in the pool. Why? Well, it's very comfortable just to drift here. Have you thought about graduate school? No. Would you mind telling me then what those four years of college were for? What was the point of all that hard work? You got me.
正懒洋洋地躺在父母的游泳池里，这时他父亲质问他。本，你在干什么？嗯，我会说我只是在池子里漂着。为什么？嗯，在这里漂着很舒服。你考虑过研究生院吗？没有。那你介意告诉我那四年大学是为了什么吗？所有那些努力工作的意义何在？你问倒我了。
Now listen, Ben. Tony, do you ever come by people who sound like Ben, people who are just drifting through life? Frequently I do. Certainly at some point in our lives, we all feel that way that what we're ultimately doing is sort of drifting through life, although not everybody's in a pool when doing so. I'm thinking that some of these moments must come, especially during transitions in life. When young people are leaving college and going into the workplace or people are in the
现在听着，本。托尼，你有没有遇到过像本那样的人，那些在生活中随波逐流的人？我经常遇到。当然，在我们生命中的某个时刻，我们都会有这种感觉，觉得我们最终所做的就是随波逐流，尽管并不是每个人都在游泳池里。我想，其中一些时刻必然会到来，尤其是在人生的过渡期。当年轻人离开大学进入职场，或者人们处于
middle part of their careers, they're deciding whether they want a second career or whether they want a retire or they're moving into retirement, I'm assuming that these moments might be more likely than others to bring out the sense of self-doubt. Yeah, that's an interesting observation in that maybe feelings of languishing are actually not as random as they may seem. Particularly the examples you've given at transition points of having just graduated or having just retired, a lot of the identity contingencies, ways that the ways in which we think ourselves are interwoven into the everyday life experiences. And so the school relationships I have or the work relationships I have, when those things
职业生涯的中期，他们正在决定是想要第二次职业生涯，还是想要退休，或者正在步入退休生活，我假设这些时刻比其他时刻更容易引发自我怀疑。是的，这是一个有趣的观察，也许这种“萎靡不振”的感觉并不像看起来那么随机。特别是你提到的那些过渡点，比如刚毕业或刚退休，许多身份的偶然性，以及我们思考自身的方式，都与日常生活经验交织在一起。所以，我拥有的学校关系或工作关系，当这些事情
end or come to an end, it might be that I start to wonder, well, who am I? What am I going to do today? And languishing isn't just a description of sort of wallowing in a pool, a float in a pool, it is an attempt to describe a whole set of affective, emotional, behavioral circumstances of simply not feeling engaged with one's life. There's sort of a disconnection. And so you're sort of in this space, as I've experienced it, where you can't fully make sense of up or down heads or tails because you're languishing, you can't keep score of how to move forward and get more of what you want, less of what you don't like. You're sort of in the wind.
结束或走到尽头时，我可能会开始怀疑，嗯，我是谁？我今天要做什么？而“萎靡不振”不仅仅是对在游泳池里漂浮这种状态的描述，它试图描述一整套情感、情绪和行为状况，即简单地感觉不到与自己生活的联系。这是一种脱节。所以，正如我所经历的那样，你处于这样一个空间里，你无法完全理清头绪，分不清上下左右，因为你处于萎靡状态，你无法衡量如何前进，如何获得更多你想要的，减少更多你不喜欢的。你就像是在风中飘荡。
I think it's a good way of describing it. And emotionally, I mean, self-doubt is probably at one end of the spectrum, and at at one end of the spectrum, and at the other end of the spectrum, you know, it can probably go as far as despair of really feeling like you don't know where you're headed, and you don't know how to figure out how to get there. I agree. A truly unsettling situation would be to really not know what's next. You can imagine how unsettling that would be for people and confusing, especially when they're in context that are sort of demanding of them answers to the questions, what are you going to do next? And to not have an answer to that can be really off-putting and unsettling.
我认为这是一个很好的描述。从情感上讲，自我怀疑可能处于光谱的一端，而光谱的另一端，你知道，它可能延伸到绝望，真的感觉不到自己要去哪里，也不知道如何弄清楚该怎么到达那里。我同意。一个真正令人不安的情况是，真的不知道接下来会发生什么。你可以想象这对人们来说是多么令人不安和困惑，尤其是当他们处于那种要求他们回答“你接下来要做什么？”这类问题的环境中时。而没有答案真的会让人感到沮丧和不安。
You once ran an experiment where you asked people to report in the morning how purposeful they felt and then report in the evening how purposeful the day had been. What did you find? The people were largely inaccurate. They tended to overestimate how purposeful they would feel that day. So waking up in the morning feeling like today is going to be a very purposeful day. But when you actually follow up with people at the end of the day, they actually weren't as purposeful as they thought they were going to be, which is not
你曾经做过一个实验，要求人们在早上报告他们感觉有多强的目标感，然后在晚上报告这一天过得有多么有目标。你发现了什么？人们大多不准确。他们倾向于高估自己那天会感受到的目标感。所以早上醒来时觉得今天会是非常有目标的一天。但当你真正跟进人们在一天结束时的感受时，他们实际上并没有他们想象中那么有目标，这并不
wholly unsurprising. Life happens, right? And so over the course of the day, you get busy with the tasks of everyday life. You go to work, you have conversations, and oh, by the end of the day, I didn't get to the things I really set out to do. But what it reveals is that it may actually be important to consider the subjective appraisal that we may feel purposeful, differentially across the day. And we may wake up with a lot of energy to go out and conquer the day. But over the course of the day, we may not get quite as near that ultimate potential as we thought. Life can get in the way of feeling as purposeful as we
完全令人惊讶。生活总会发生点什么，对吧？所以在一天的过程中，你忙于日常生活的琐事。你去工作，进行交谈，哦，到了一天结束时，我并没有完成我真正打算做的事情。但这揭示了，考虑我们可能在一天中不同时间感受到不同程度的目标感的主观评估可能实际上很重要。我们可能醒来时充满活力，想要去征服这一天。但在这一天的过程中，我们可能并没有像我们想象的那样接近那个最终的潜力。生活可能会阻碍我们感受到像我们
intended to. You mentioned the idea of subjective experience a second ago, and I want to stay with that idea for a moment. Many people confuse a life that has meaning with one that has purpose. You say that meaning involves looking backwards and purpose involves looking forward. Can you explain the distinction between those two things? Sure. I certainly think these terms, meaning and purpose,
预期的那样有目标。你刚才提到了主观体验的概念，我想在这个想法上停留一会儿。许多人混淆了有意义的生活和有目标的生活。你说意义涉及回顾过去，而目标涉及展望未来。你能解释一下这两者之间的区别吗？当然。我确实认为这些术语，意义和目标，
can become sort of conceptually tethered in our minds. Meaning is sort of like making sense of the world as it's happened or is happening, whereas purpose may not be as much about comprehending what's happened as it is about aspiring or attending to accomplish something that's ahead of you. I feel like we live in a culture that talks a lot about goals. You know, getting into college, graduating from college, getting married, getting I feel like we live in a culture that talks a lot about goals. Getting into college, graduating from college, getting married, getting promoted, talk a moment about the difference between having goals and having purpose.
在我们的脑海中可能会在概念上相互关联。意义有点像是理解已经发生或正在发生的世界，而目标可能与其说是理解已经发生的事情，不如说是渴望或致力于完成你面前的事情。我觉得我们生活在一个谈论目标很多的文化中。你知道，考上大学，大学毕业，结婚，得到我感觉我们生活在一个谈论目标很多的文化中。考上大学，大学毕业，结婚，得到晋升，谈谈拥有目标和拥有目标感之间的区别。
Goals might be thought of as intentions that can be accomplished, whereas we tend to think about purpose as an intentionality or life aim, meaning it is always in front of you. So, for example, a goal of graduating, I can accomplish that goal. I can set a goal of getting a job, but a purpose might be something like being a caring father. I can perhaps evidence it on a given day when I'm at my best, but it's hard to imagine accomplishing that, being fully done with the task of that. And so a purpose might be an organizer of our goals, such that when I accomplish goals, it's my purpose that tells me what are the goals that I should be pursuing next.
目标可以被认为是能够完成的意图，而我们倾向于将目标感视为一种意向性或人生志向，这意味着它总是摆在你面前。例如，毕业的目标，我可以完成那个目标。我可以设定一个找工作的目标，但目标感可能更像是“做一个有爱心的父亲”。我或许可以在我表现最好的某一天证明这一点，但很难想象能完成那个任务，彻底结束它。所以，目标感可能是我们目标的组织者，这样当我完成目标时，是我的目标感告诉我接下来应该追求什么目标。
You know, I'm thinking about the story of Andrea Agassi, the tennis player, you know, in his autobiography, he writes at one point that even though he was a world champion, he was desperately unhappy, you know, in a 2017 article in the Guardian, he says, despite being good at it, I had a deep resentment and even hatred of tennis. I felt nothing every day is groundhog day and what's the point. And to me that's so poignant that someone who is literally at the top of their game can feel like they are drifting just as much as Benjamin Braddock in that swimming pool. Yes, that's a fascinating insight, right, because it's a very profound goal to strive to be
你知道，我在想网球运动员安德烈·阿加西的故事，你知道，在他的自传中，他写道，尽管他是世界冠军，但他非常不快乐，你知道，在《卫报》2017 年的一篇文章中，他说，尽管我很擅长网球，但我对网球有着深深的怨恨，甚至憎恨。我每天都感觉不到任何东西，就像《土拨鼠之日》一样，意义何在。对我来说，这非常令人心酸，一个真正处于巅峰状态的人，竟然可以感觉自己和游泳池里的本杰明·布拉多克一样在随波逐流。是的，这是一个迷人的洞察，对吧，因为努力成为
number one and to be successful and have as much talent as it would take to be number one in the world and in anything that you're doing. And perhaps as you're enroute to number one, there's always this intentionality, there's always a higher seed that you can move forward to. But what happens when you've accomplished it? The game changes. Now it's the story of holding on to that, of maintenance. And so I think that's a wonderful illustration of what can happen when we conflate a goal with a purpose is if a goal can be accomplished, it does raise questions about what becomes of you once you've accomplished it. Purpose is not synonymous with what the world sees in front of you. It is entirely internally driven.
第一名并取得成功，拥有成为世界第一所需的天赋，这是一个非常深刻的目标。也许在你通往第一名的路上，总是有这种意向性，总有一个更高的种子选手你可以超越。但当你实现它之后会发生什么？游戏规则变了。现在是关于保持这个位置的故事，是关于维护的故事。所以我认为这是一个很好的例子，说明当我们混淆目标和目标感时会发生什么，如果一个目标可以被完成，它确实会引发关于你一旦完成它之后会变成什么样的问题。目标感不是世界在你面前所看到的东西的同义词。它是完全内在驱动的。
The answer to the question, what is your purpose? Is not something you can crowdsource. It's not something that you can turn to others and say, hey, tell me from your profile of you, which direction does it look like I'm heading in? It's an internal quest, and not until you realize that, you begin to ask yourself the question, who are you, what direction are you heading in, what is your purpose, would it really show up and become salient or
回答“你的目标是什么？”这个问题，不是你可以众包的事情。这不是你可以转向他人说，“嘿，从你的角度告诉我，我看起来正朝着哪个方向前进？”这是一个内在的探索，直到你意识到这一点，你开始问自己，“你是谁，你正朝着什么方向前进，你的目标是什么”，它才会真正显现出来并变得显著或
actionable to you? You know, I feel like poets and philosophers have talked about this idea for a long time, and I love what you just said that in many ways, purpose is not about what it looks like on the outside from your profile picture on Instagram. It really is what's happening on the inside. That's right. And I think that actually is poignant because there are many examples of people who,
对你来说可操作？你知道，我觉得诗人和哲学家谈论这个想法已经很久了，我喜欢你刚才说的，在很多方面，目标感并不是关于从你的 Instagram 头像上看它在外面看起来是什么样子的。它确实是关于内心正在发生的事情。没错。而且我认为这实际上很令人心酸，因为有许多例子表明，人们
from the outside, look one way, look completely self-directed and clear what they're doing. But when you ask them what direction they're heading in, they may report symptoms of languishing. A lack of purpose can affect us at many different stages of our lives. Young people, like the fictional Benjamin Brattick, might experience it as confusion and uncertainty. Working age adults might experience it as on-we, and uncertainty. Working age adults might experience it as on we, unending drudgery and tedious routines. Among older Americans, a lack of purpose
从外面看，看起来是一个样子，看起来完全是自我导向的，清楚自己在做什么。但当你问他们正朝着什么方向前进时，他们可能会报告萎靡不振的症状。缺乏目标感会影响我们生命中许多不同的阶段。像虚构的本杰明·布拉多克这样的年轻人可能会将其体验为困惑和不确定。工作年龄的成年人可能会将其体验为倦怠，和不确定。工作年龄的成年人可能会将其体验为倦怠，无休止的苦差事和乏味的例行公事。在老年美国人中，缺乏目标感
may be linked to isolation and loneliness. Purpose in other words, is essential to our well-being. It buffers us against the challenges we will all confront at various stages of our lives. It provides a measure of stability in uncertain times. The good news is that purpose is also something we can cultivate. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
可能与孤立和孤独有关。换句话说，目标感对我们的幸福至关重要。它缓冲了我们将在生命各个阶段面临的挑战。它在不确定的时期提供了一种稳定感。好消息是，目标感也是我们可以培养的东西。我们回来后继续。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
If you had to choose between a million dollars and having a sense of purpose, you might choose the money. At Cornell University, psychologist Anthony Barrow might argue you are making a mistake. Tony, I want to take nothing away from the benefits of having a great job or having money or a roof over your head. Those things are really important, especially if you don't have them. But can you talk a moment about what purpose can give us that money and material comforts cannot? First and foremost, a sense of purpose could give you a basis on which to decide, given the finite resources we have of money, of time, of energy, how should we best allocate them
如果你必须在一百万美元和拥有目标感之间做出选择，你可能会选择钱。在康奈尔大学，心理学家安东尼·巴罗可能会认为你犯了一个错误。托尼，我不想否定拥有一份好工作、有钱或有栖身之所的好处。这些事情非常重要，特别是如果你没有它们的话。但你能谈谈目标感能给我们带来什么，而金钱和物质享受却不能带来的东西吗？首先，目标感可以为你提供一个基础，让你在拥有有限的金钱、时间和精力资源的情况下，决定我们应该如何最好地分配它们
to allow us to move forward? And so money helps us purchase life's experiences. Which experiences should we purchase is fundamentally a different question in having a sense of purpose could clarify that for us? Hmm. I want to play you a clip from the movie Lost in Translation, a younger woman is asking an older man
以使我们能够前进？所以金钱帮助我们购买生活体验。我们应该购买哪些体验，这本质上是一个不同的问题，而拥有目标感可以为我们澄清这一点。嗯。我想给你播放一段电影《迷失东京》的片段，一个年轻女子正在问一个年长男子
about how to navigate some of life's challenges, and I want to play you a little exchange that they have. Does it get easier? No. Yes. It gets easier. No, yeah. Look at you.
关于如何应对生活中的一些挑战，我想播放他们之间的一小段对话。生活会变得更容易吗？不。会。它会变得更容易。不，是的。看看你。
Thanks. The more you know who you are and what you want, the less the other things I'm saying. The more you know who you are and what you want, the less you're going to let things upset you. Can you talk about the role of purpose as a mood-regulator, Tony? There seems to be accumulating evidence that one of the benefits of feeling a sense of purpose is that it can help us remain even keel
谢谢。你越了解自己是谁以及你想要什么，你就越不会让其他事情……我正在说。你越了解自己是谁以及你想要什么，你就越不会让事情让你心烦意乱。你能谈谈目标感作为情绪调节器的作用吗，托尼？似乎有越来越多的证据表明，拥有目标感的好处之一是它可以帮助我们在压力或挑战时刻，甚至在令人振奋的经历中，保持平稳。
in moments of stress or challenge and sometimes even uplifting experiences. We've done studies where we ask people to report challenges or difficult experiences in the unfolding context of their everyday lives. And as you might expect, on days in which people tend to report stressors, they also tend to report increases in distress.
我们做过研究，要求人们报告他们日常生活展开过程中的挑战或困难经历。正如你所料，在人们倾向于报告压力源的日子里，他们也倾向于报告痛苦的增加。
They tend to feel worse on days when they're reporting more stressors. However, purposeful individuals or those that tend to score higher than their peers on measures of purpose in life, their stressful days kind of look like non-stressful days for the rest of us. In other words, it's almost as if it's helping them navigate or smooth the course for them. Now I should say, it is not the case that purposeful people experience any less stress
在他们报告更多压力源的日子里，他们往往感觉更糟。然而，有目标感的人，或者那些在人生目标衡量标准上得分高于同龄人的人，他们的压力日看起来就像我们其他人的非压力日一样。换句话说，这几乎就像是在帮助他们导航或为他们平滑道路。现在我应该说，并不是说有目标感的人经历的压力
or challenge in their lives. In fact, in our studies, sometimes purposeful people report more day-to-day stressors than their peers who report lower levels of purpose in life. But on days in which people tend to report stressors, having a sense of purpose seems to buffer or mitigate the ill-intended consequences of stressors. So it's almost as if having purpose allows you to keep your eyes on the horizon, if you will,
或挑战更少。事实上，在我们的研究中，有时有目标感的人报告的日常压力源比那些报告目标感水平较低的同龄人更多。但在人们倾向于报告压力源的日子里，拥有目标感似乎缓冲或减轻了压力源带来的不良后果。所以这几乎就像拥有目标感让你能够保持目光注视地平线，如果你愿意的话，
so that the day-to-day challenges that are both, you know, the good and bad, tend to knock you off course a little less, because in some ways your eyes are focused on the future. That's correct. And what's remarkable about this growing set of studies is it seems to be evident both in the context of stressors and in the context of positive events or uplifts. So on days when good things happen, as you'd expect, people tend to report increases in things like positive affect, life satisfaction or self-esteem. But individuals who score high and measures of purpose in life, on those days when good things happen, they tend to look emotionally even keel.
这样日常的挑战，无论是好的还是坏的，都不太容易让你偏离轨道，因为在某种程度上，你的眼睛专注于未来。没错。而且这组不断增长的研究中引人注目的是，它似乎在压力源的背景下和积极事件或提升的背景下都很明显。所以，在好事发生的日子里，正如你所料，人们倾向于报告积极情绪、生活满意度或自尊等方面的增加。但那些在人生目标衡量标准上得分高的人，在好事发生的日子里，他们往往看起来情绪平稳。
It's almost as if that good thing didn't happen. And I'll just say, although that may be jarring at first, it's like purpose almost blocks you from reaping the benefits of a good thing. Over time, you would not want your emotional tone to be bouncing around based upon the experiences that are happening to you. Over the course of one's lifespan, it might be beneficial to remain even keel or as close as possible to life's experiences and feel good irrespective of what's happening around you. You once asked volunteers in an experiment to climb a steep hill and at the bottom of the
这几乎就像那件好事没有发生一样。我只想说，虽然这起初可能令人震惊，但这就像目标感几乎阻止了你从好事中获得好处。随着时间的推移，你不会希望你的情绪基调根据发生在你身上的经历而上下波动。在一个人的一生中，保持平稳或尽可能接近生活体验，无论周围发生什么都感觉良好，这可能是有益的。你曾经要求实验中的志愿者爬上一座陡峭的山，在山脚下，
hill, some were asked to write about a movie and others were asked to write about something that gave them a sense of purpose. Can you tell us what you found once the volunteer has got to the top of the hill? In this particular experiment, after writing about either the movie that they had seen or their sense of purpose, individuals traversed a steep incline. And as they arrived at the top, we asked them to report how steep was this hill and how much effort did it take them to get to the top. Now, for those individuals who had written about the most recent movie they had seen, there was a pretty clear positive correlation or a strong relationship between how steep they thought the hill was and how much
一些人被要求写一部电影，另一些人被要求写一些给他们带来目标感的东西。你能告诉我们一旦志愿者到达山顶，你发现了什么吗？在这个特定的实验中，在写下他们看过的电影或他们的目标感之后，个人穿过了一个陡峭的斜坡。当他们到达顶部时，我们要求他们报告这座山有多陡，以及他们花了多少努力才到达顶部。现在，对于那些写下他们看过的最新电影的人来说，他们认为山有多陡和他们认为花了多少
effort they thought it took to get to the top. Whereas individuals who had written about purpose, briefly before traversing this incline, when they got to the top, they showed less of a relationship between the estimated incline of the hill and how much effort they said it took to get to the top. One thing I should say, because I think it's relevant to the conversation, is we also had another condition in this study in which we asked people to write about their goals that they intended to accomplish once they got to the top of the hill to study with a friend to meet somebody for lunch to go home whatever they might say that they were going to do once they got to the top of the hill and those individuals who
努力才到达顶部之间存在相当明确的正相关或强关系。而那些在穿过这个斜坡前简要写下目标感的人，当他们到达顶部时，他们表现出估计的山坡倾斜度和他们说花了多少努力才到达顶部之间的关系较弱。有一件事我应该说，因为我认为它与对话相关，我们在这个研究中还有另一个条件，我们要求人们写下他们打算在到达山顶后完成的目标，和朋友一起学习，和某人见面吃午饭，回家，无论他们可能说他们到达山顶后要做什么，而那些
wrote about a goal they actually did not show the same relationship between estimated incline and reported effort as the purpose-writing condition. And I think the insight to be drawn here is goals can become obstacles to the thing you most want to do. If you get me to think about my goal, well, then this hill is the effort. This is the obstacle between me and where I'm going to be in a few minutes when I get to the top, whereas a sense of purpose seems to decouple those things in a way,
写下目标的人，他们实际上并没有表现出与目标感写作条件相同的估计倾斜度和报告努力之间的关系。我认为这里可以得出的洞察是，目标可能成为你最想做的事情的障碍。如果你让我思考我的目标，那么这座山就是努力。这是我和几分钟后到达山顶时我要去的地方之间的障碍，而目标感似乎以某种方式将这些事情解耦了，
because I'm not thinking about what I'm going to do immediately at the top. I'm thinking about my general direction in life. I also understand there's been research that suggests that people who have a sense of purpose appear more attractive to others. Is that possibly true? There does seem to be some suggestive evidence that individuals who report a stronger sense of purpose in life have a kind of interpersonal appeal. This is the work of Tyler Stillman and his colleagues. They have shown that our sort of judgments of attractiveness of people
因为我没有在想我到达顶部后立即要做什么。我在想我的人生总体方向。我还了解到有研究表明，拥有目标感的人对他人看起来更有吸引力。这可能是真的吗？确实有一些暗示性的证据表明，报告人生目标感更强的人有一种人际吸引力。这是泰勒·斯蒂尔曼（Tyler Stillman）及其同事的工作。他们表明，我们对人们吸引力的判断
seem to have this sort of latent relationship with how strongly of a sense of purpose an individual might feel. And it's not really, I don't think, a story of just physical attractiveness, but a story of just likeability and wanting to be a round person or wanting to be friends with them.
似乎与一个人可能感受到的目标感有多强有着这种潜在的关系。我不认为这真的是关于身体吸引力的故事，而是关于讨人喜欢和想要和某人在一起或想要和他们成为朋友的故事。
Their data suggests that people who score highly on measures of purpose tend to enjoy this benefit of the world around them. Their data suggests that people who score highly on measures of purpose tend to enjoy this benefit of the world around them. It's almost as if we can see that this person is heading somewhere. There's something about them and they have a directionality to them. You know, as I was reading Tyler Stilman's study, I remember the poem that I had read some years ago, this is by W. H. Audden, where he talks about the very same idea. He says, you need not see what someone is doing to know if it is his vocation.
他们的数据表明，在目标衡量标准上得分高的人往往享受周围世界的这种好处。他们的数据表明，在目标衡量标准上得分高的人往往享受周围世界的这种好处。这几乎就像我们可以看到这个人正要去某个地方。他们身上有一些东西，他们有一种方向感。你知道，当我阅读泰勒·斯蒂尔曼的研究时，我记得我几年前读过的一首诗，这是 W. H. 奥登（W. H. Auden）写的，他谈到了同样的想法。他说，你不需要看到某人在做什么就知道那是否是他的职业。
You have only to watch his eyes, a cook mixing a sauce, a surgeon making a primary incision, a clerk completing a bill of lading, where the same wrapped expression, forgetting themselves in a function. How beautiful it is that I, on the object look. I'm wondering, Tony, when you listen to that poem, is this speaking to what you said a second ago, that in some ways there's something, it's not sort of attractive and sort of a physical attractiveness sense, but it's something that draws us to people who seem to be truly engaged in what they're doing.
你只需要观察他的眼睛，一个正在搅拌酱汁的厨师，一个正在做初步切口的医生，一个正在填写提单的职员，有着同样的专注表情，在功能中忘记了自己。我看着物体，它是多么美丽。托尼，我想知道，当你听那首诗时，这是否在说你刚才说的话，在某种程度上，有一些东西，它不是那种身体吸引力意义上的吸引力，而是某种吸引我们去关注那些似乎真正投入到他们正在做的事情中的人的东西。
First, I think the poem is beautiful and interestingly, there is suggestive evidence that people who score highly on measures of felt purpose tend to have broader and deeper social networks. So, it's as if there may be something they're up to that requires them to be in connection with broader circles of community. But it could also just as easily be the case that when you're pursuing something that is meaningful to you, there's an attractiveness to that. That people find you because you're headed in a direction and maybe goes back to this languishing point. For a person is not directed. If a person does not feel a sense of purpose
首先，我认为这首诗很美，有趣的是，有暗示性的证据表明，在感受到的目标衡量标准上得分高的人往往拥有更广泛和更深厚的社交网络。所以，这似乎是他们正在做的事情需要他们与更广泛的社区圈子建立联系。但也同样容易出现的情况是，当你追求对你有意义的事情时，这本身就有一种吸引力。人们找到你是因为你正朝着一个方向前进，也许这回到了这个萎靡不振的点。对于一个没有方向的人。如果一个人没有感受到目标感
and start to pursue a particular aim, it may be more difficult for the world around you to know just how to connect to you. But it seems like if you're directed, you're heading in a direction. There's, you know, perhaps there's an energy around that that is attractive and imperceptible by others. attractive and imperceptible by others.
并开始追求一个特定的目标，周围的世界可能更难知道如何与你建立联系。但看起来如果你是有方向的，你正朝着一个方向前进。有，你知道，也许周围有一种吸引人的能量，并且被他人察觉不到。被他人察觉不到。
Tony and his colleagues measure where the people have a sense of purpose by asking some remarkably simple questions. You can ask yourself these questions. In fact, you can ask yourself these questions right now. Do you feel your life has a clear direction? Do you feel your life has a clear direction? Do you feel your daily activities are engaging? Important? This leads us to a crucial idea. A sense of purpose is not an objective truth, but a subjective experience.
托尼和他的同事通过问一些非常简单的问题来衡量人们是否有目标感。你可以问自己这些问题。事实上，你现在就可以问自己这些问题。你觉得你的生活有明确的方向吗？你觉得你的生活有明确的方向吗？你觉得你的日常活动引人入胜吗？重要吗？这引出了一个关键的想法。目标感不是客观真理，而是一种主观体验。
My colleagues and I tend to think about purpose as a sense, a perceptible sense that life has a sense of direction. So it's simply feeling like your life has purpose, for which seems to be a strong predictor of health and well-being. So let's talk about the idea of health and well-being for a moment. What does the research say about the connections between having a sense of purpose and health outcomes? One of the most compelling findings I could think to share is that having a sense of purpose
我和我的同事倾向于将目标感视为一种感觉，一种可感知的、生活有方向感的感觉。所以这仅仅是感觉你的生活有目标，这似乎是健康和幸福的强有力预测指标。所以让我们谈谈健康和幸福的想法。研究对拥有目标感和健康结果之间的联系有什么说法？我能想到的最令人信服的发现之一是拥有目标感
in life predicts longevity. But beyond longevity, there is a whole constellation of studies to suggest. Purpose is associated with a whole host of physical and physiological health outcomes. For example, purposeful individuals report lower incidents of heart attack or stroke. Purposeful individuals recover faster from certain kinds of surgery. Purposeful people report feeling less psychosomatic symptoms, so headaches and stomach aches in the context of their everyday lives. So the health profile of purpose seems to be
在生活中可以预测长寿。但除了长寿之外，还有一整套研究表明。目标感与一系列身体和生理健康结果相关。例如，有目标感的人报告心脏病发作或中风的发生率较低。有目标感的人从某些手术中恢复得更快。有目标感的人报告感觉到的心身症状较少，即在日常生活中的头痛和胃痛。所以目标感的健康状况似乎
especially positive. I understand there are also cognitive benefits that come with a sense of purpose. Sure, so there's also suggestive evidence that individuals with a sense of purpose show slower rates of cognitive decline over the course of aging and lower risk of developing Alzheimer's disease as well. So there's indeed suggestive evidence that purpose is associated with again a host of
特别积极。我知道拥有目标感也会带来认知方面的好处。当然，也有暗示性的证据表明，有目标感的人在衰老过程中表现出较慢的认知衰退率，患阿尔茨海默病的风险也较低。所以确实有暗示性的证据表明目标感与一系列
cognitive benefits. We spoke at the beginning of the segment about a thought experiment where I was giving you the choice between having a million dollars and having a sense of purpose. In reality though, you and others have found that having a sense of purpose is not often at odds with financial success. And in some ways the two things might be correlated. Can you talk about that work? Sure. In the context of our lab, we've noted having a sense of purpose in life is associated with greater self-reported income and greater net worth. And I want to speak to this in relationship to another study because I think there's an important relationship here is having a sense of purpose is also associated with the lower levels of impulsivity.
认知益处相关。我们在本节开头谈到了一个思想实验，我让你在拥有一百万美元和拥有目标感之间做出选择。然而在现实中，你和其他人发现拥有目标感并不经常与经济成功相冲突。在某些方面，这两件事可能是相关的。你能谈谈那项工作吗？当然。在我们的实验室背景下，我们注意到在生活中拥有目标感与更高的自我报告收入和更高的净资产相关。我想结合另一项研究来谈谈这一点，因为我认为这里有一个重要的关系，即拥有目标感也与较低的冲动水平相关。
So in a study where individuals were given a chance to take right now a small monetary reward. They tended to opt for a larger downstream reward. And the notion that having a sense of purpose in life is implicated in lower levels of impulsivity, I think illuminates the long game that purposeful individuals might be playing. They're thinking about not the here and now, but about saving, about generating more for later. I'm wondering if you can talk a moment about purpose not at an individual level. And this might be difficult to do because it's harder to run experiments at a societal level.
所以在一项研究中，人们有机会立即获得小额金钱奖励。他们倾向于选择更大的后续奖励。而拥有人生目标感与较低冲动水平有关的观念，我认为阐明了有目标感的人可能正在玩的长线游戏。他们想的不是此时此地，而是关于储蓄，关于为以后创造更多。我想知道你是否能谈谈目标感，而不是在个人层面。这可能很难做到，因为在社会层面进行实验更难。
But it seems to me that there are times in the lives of different societies when societies feel like they have purpose and when societies feel like they are adrift. Can you talk about this idea of purpose as a driver of change, especially at the large level to societal level? You know, I have to confess, we tend to measure purpose as this individual asset, this individual resource that a person could cultivate. But what does that look like in a collective sense?
但在我看来，在不同社会的生命中，总有一些时候社会觉得他们有目标，而有些时候社会觉得他们随波逐流。你能谈谈这个作为变革驱动力的目标感想法吗，特别是在宏观层面，即社会层面？你知道，我必须承认，我们倾向于将目标感衡量为这种个人资产，这种一个人可以培养的个人资源。但这在集体意义上是什么样子的呢？
I can say, I notice even in political rhetoric when candidates call on our collective sense of purpose, it is a reminder that even as an individual, we belong to something larger than ourselves. I just wanna do God's will. And he is allowed me to go up to the mountain. And I've looked over and I've seen the promised land. I may not get that with you. I've looked over and I've seen the Promised Land.
我可以肯定地说，我甚至在政治修辞中注意到，当候选人呼吁我们的集体目标感时，这提醒我们，即使作为个人，我们也属于比我们自己更大的东西。我只想做上帝的旨意。他允许我登上山顶。我俯瞰过，我看到了应许之地。我可能不会和你一起到达那里。我俯瞰过，我看到了应许之地。
I may not get there with you, but I want you to know the night that we as a people will get to the Promised Land. In his articulation of a dream, Dr. Martin Luther King Jr. invited us to imagine a world that was not yet present. And I think that's a profound yet again, a profound insight into a distinction between a goal that we can accomplish and a purpose that long after us, we can still be intending to move towards. The aspirational tone is so vivid, even in his reminder that he may not arrive there with us, but it was still worth the effort. It was still worth the pursuit and reminding us that we are empowered to carry this forward.
我可能不会和你一起到达那里，但我希望你知道，我们作为一个民族，那个夜晚将会到达应许之地。在他对梦想的阐述中，马丁·路德·金博士邀请我们想象一个尚未存在的世界。我认为这又是一个深刻的洞察，关于我们可以完成的目标和我们可以在我们之后很久仍然打算朝着它前进的目标感之间的区别。这种抱负的基调是如此生动，即使在他提醒我们他可能不会和我们一起到达那里时，但它仍然值得努力。它仍然值得追求，并提醒我们，我们有权将其发扬光大。
I want to play you a clip from the the late Viktor Frankl, holocaust survivor and author of the bestselling book, Man's Search for Meaning. Here he is in an interview. The lesson one could learn in Auschwitz and in other concentration camps,
我想给你播放一段已故维克多·弗兰克尔（Viktor Frankl）的片段，他是大屠杀幸存者，也是畅销书《活出意义来》（Man's Search for Meaning）的作者。这是他在一次采访中。一个人在奥斯威辛集中营和其他集中营中可以学到的教训，
in the final analysis was those who were oriented toward a meaning to be fulfilled by them in the future were most likely to survive. And this has been confirmed afterwards by American Navy and Army Psychiatrists in Japanese prison of war camps, the orientation taught a future, taught a task, a personal task, waiting for them to be fulfilled in their future, or another person whom they were loving to be met again. This was what was decisively upheld in these people. So the orientation beyond oneself, you see the question was not just survivors, but there had to be a why of survivors. Tony, talk about this a moment because there's
归根结底是，那些面向未来有待他们去实现的意义的人最有可能生存下来。这一点后来得到了美国海军和陆军精神病学家在日本战俘营中的证实，这种面向未来的导向，教导了一个任务，一个等待他们在未来去完成的个人任务，或者另一个他们所爱的人将再次相遇。这就是在这些人身上决定性地坚持下来的东西。所以超越自我的导向，你看，问题不仅仅是幸存者，而是必须有一个幸存者的“为什么”。托尼，谈谈这一点，因为有一个
a such an important and powerful idea that even in the horrors of the. Tony, talk about this a moment because there's a such an important and powerful idea that even in the horrors of the concentration camp, the question was not just survival, as Victor Frankl says, but they had to be a why in order to have survival. It is the most eloquent putting of the question, do you have a reason for living? I guess the better way of saying this is, there can be a physical death, and Victor Franco was very keenly aware of that. But before that, there can be a psychological death
如此重要和强大的想法，即使在集中营的恐怖中。托尼，谈谈这一点，因为有一个如此重要和强大的想法，即使在集中营的恐怖中，问题不仅仅是生存，正如维克多·弗兰克尔所说，而是必须有一个“为什么”才能生存。这是对“你是否有活下去的理由”这个问题的最雄辩的表达。我想更好的说法是，可能会有肉体上的死亡，维克多·弗兰克尔对此非常敏锐地意识到。但在那之前，可能会有心理上的死亡，
where a person sees nothing else out ahead of themselves. And I think what he's speaking to is the profound necessity of feeling like there is something out in front of you. There is something that you have yet to accomplish that you can move towards as a way of surviving, of psychologically surviving and persisting. Purpose is an ancient concept. We, as a species, have been grappling with this concept forever. But I think Victor Franco's contribution is that we can take seriously the psychological enterprise of purpose as a deep and profound resource that is worth taking our time to cultivate
一个人在前方看不到任何东西。我认为他所说的是，感觉前方有东西的深刻必要性。有一些你尚未完成的事情，你可以朝着它前进，作为一种生存、心理上生存和坚持下去的方式。目标是一个古老的概念。作为一个物种，我们一直在与这个概念搏斗。但我认为维克多·弗兰克尔的贡献在于，我们可以认真对待目标感的心理事业，将其作为一种深厚而深刻的资源，值得我们花时间去培养
this sense so that we see ourselves persisting in time and ultimately contributing to the world that is before us. When we come back, it's one thing to say that purpose is really important. But if you don't have it, how do you find it? Is purpose something to be discovered or can it be developed, honed and cultivated. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Having a sense of purpose is like a secret super power. Psychologist Anthony Barrow argues it can improve your health, your cognitive abilities, your longevity.
这种感觉，这样我们就能看到自己在时间中坚持下去，并最终为我们面前的世界做出贡献。我们回来后，说目标感非常重要是一回事。但如果你没有它，你如何找到它？目标感是需要被发现的东西，还是可以被发展、磨练和培养的。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。拥有目标感就像一种秘密的超能力。心理学家安东尼·巴罗认为它可以改善你的健康、认知能力和长寿。
It can even make you appear more attractive. We've talked about the tennis player, André Agassi, and how, even though he was very successful, he came to hate tennis. But that's not the end of Agassi's story. When he realized his life felt empty, André Agassi decided to approach tennis differently. He realized people were coming to watch him play, that he was giving others joy. He started to see himself as a role model. Here he is describing that journey of taking ownership over his choices. Ownership meant feeling grateful for being and having the chance to start over.
它甚至可以让你看起来更有吸引力。我们谈到了网球运动员安德烈·阿加西，以及尽管他非常成功，但他后来如何憎恨网球。但这并不是阿加西故事的终点。当他意识到他的生活感到空虚时，安德烈·阿加西决定以不同的方式对待网球。他意识到人们来看他比赛，他给别人带来了快乐。他开始把自己视为榜样。这是他在描述那种对自己选择承担责任的旅程。承担责任意味着对存在和有机会重新开始感到感激。
for being and having the chance to start over. Climbing out of that hole that I dug for myself, that's when I started choosing to believe that each of us have a plan for our life. A purpose to fulfill. Body of work to create. A reason to be. Tony, you seem to have had the remarkable good fortune of having a sense of direction through much of your life.
对存在和有机会重新开始感到感激。从我自己挖的那个洞里爬出来，那时我开始选择相信我们每个人对自己的生活都有一个计划。一个要实现的目标。要创造的作品。存在的理由。托尼，你似乎有非常好的运气，在你的大部分生活中都有方向感。
I want to talk about some things you experienced growing up that may have helped you on this journey. You were adopted as a child, your black, your parents are white, you could very easily have come to see yourself as a fish out of water. But early on you encountered a program called 4H. Tell me where you grew up and for the many hidden brain listeners who are not in the United States. What is the 4H program and how did it touch your life? 4H is a national youth development program that has been in existence for over 115 years. And when I was a child, I participated in a 4-H program. I was living in Iowa, Northeast Iowa, in Bremer County. So shout
我想谈谈你成长过程中经历的一些事情，这些经历可能对你的人生旅程有所帮助。你从小被领养，你是黑人，你的父母是白人，你很容易会觉得自己格格不入。但你很早就接触了一个叫4H的项目。告诉我你在哪里长大，对于许多不在美国的Hidden Brain听众来说，4H项目是什么？它又是如何触动你的生活的？4H是一个已经存在超过115年的全国性青少年发展项目。我小时候参加过4H项目。我当时住在爱荷华州，爱荷华州东北部的布雷默县。所以向
out to the Bremer County 4-H program that I was a part of. My 4-H program was heavily centered on agricultural development. And it gave the young people that were involved in this program a chance to learn agricultural skills, how to grow crops, how to take care of animals, that kind of thing. I never thought about being in 4-H as participating in really a program. It was just kind of the cool thing to do. I didn't remember joining anything or signing up. It was just all of my friends and the parents of my friends were involved with 4H. It was a way in which we were socialized into the work that we did from day to day. Help me understand how a program that taught you how to farm, how to raise animals, how
我参加过的布雷默县4H项目致敬。我的4H项目主要集中在农业发展上。它让参与这个项目的年轻人有机会学习农业技能，如何种植作物，如何照顾动物，诸如此类的事情。我从未想过参加4H是在参加一个什么项目。这只是当时一件很酷的事情。我不记得自己加入或注册过什么。我所有的朋友和朋友的父母都参与了4H。这是一种让我们融入日常工作的方式。帮我理解一下，一个教你如何务农、如何饲养动物的项目，是如何
does that help you become a psychologist at Cornell University? I don't see the path. That's a wonderful question. Within the context of 4-H, we had just a tremendous number of opportunities to practice different things. And one of the things we were invited to practice was public speaking. We had to present lessons we were learning to other 4-H members in different venues. Sometimes it was our closest friends and families, other times it was strangers at county fairs or state fairs. But over the years, I had a chance to present on how to notch pigs'
让你成为康奈尔大学的心理学家的？我看不出其中的路径。这是一个很好的问题。在4H的背景下，我们有大量的机会去练习不同的事情。我们被邀请练习的事情之一就是公开演讲。我们必须向其他4H成员展示我们正在学习的课程，地点各不相同。有时是我们最亲密的朋友和家人，有时是县集市或州集市上的陌生人。但多年来，我有机会展示如何给猪
ears and the different ways of doing that. I had a chance to present on how to tie different kinds of knots. In one particular time, I had a chance to present on how to grow certain crops in different soil types. And over the years of public speaking and presenting, I think I actually got good at it. I remember in one particular moment of presenting on how to grow certain crops and the judges paying attention to my presentation, taking notes of my style and the delivery and the different things I was saying about the soil.
剪耳，以及各种不同的方法。我有机会展示如何打各种结。有一次，我还有机会展示如何在不同的土壤类型中种植某些作物。多年来的公开演讲和展示，我想我确实变得擅长了。我记得有一次展示如何种植某些作物时，评委们关注着我的演讲，记录下我的风格、表达方式以及我关于土壤所说的不同内容。
But I also remember the audience. There were people who were not actually judging me, but there to learn about different crop types and soil types. And that to be eight or nine years old, presenting to an audience of adults, teaching adults about the thing that I knew about was a profound experience.
但我也记得观众。有些人并不是在评判我，而是来学习不同作物类型和土壤类型的。对于一个八九岁的孩子来说，向一群成年人演讲，教成年人我所知道的事情，那是一次深刻的经历。
And I had a little jar where I was showing different layers of the soil. And I remember going away and coming back and seeing the judges had placed a red ribbon around my presentation, which essentially translated to second place. And I've always been pretty salty about that day, that I got a second place on a presentation.
我有一个小罐子，用来展示土壤的不同层次。我记得我走开又回来时，看到评委们在我的展示品上系了一条红丝带，这基本上意味着第二名。对于那天只得了第二名，我一直耿耿于怀。
But it stuck with me, that I realized I had something to say. And the way I went about saying it mattered, because people might understand the world they're living in differently as a function of what I'm saying. And I could get better. There was room for improvement. But that was a profound experience for me as a function of what I'm saying. And I could get better. There was room for improvement, but that was a profound experience for me as a young person. So one of the things that jumped out of me
但这对我影响深远，我意识到我有话要说。我表达的方式很重要，因为人们可能会根据我的话，以不同的方式理解他们所处的世界。而且我可以做得更好。还有改进的空间。但对于年轻时的我来说，那是一次深刻的经历。所以，你刚才说的话中有一点引起了我的注意
at what you just said was that you discovered that you had something to say, and part of what was actually discovering a little bit of who you were, and what kind of a person you were, can you talk about this connection between programs that in some ways help people discover who they are, discover a sense of identity, and the really vital connection between a sense
那就是你发现自己有话要说，而这其中一部分实际上是发现了一点点你是谁，以及你是一个什么样的人。你能谈谈这些项目在某种程度上帮助人们发现自我、发现身份认同感，以及身份认同感与拥有目标感之间那种至关重要的联系吗？没错。事实证明，4H确实是一个青少年发展项目，一个充满善意的脚手架式体验项目。真正棒的是，越来越多的研究表明，青少年项目的某些特征有能力引导年轻人
of identity and having a sense of purpose? Right. It turns out, after all, that 4-H is, in fact, a youth development program, a well-intended program of scaffolded experiences. And what's really neat about this is that there's a growing course of studies to suggest certain features of youth programs have the ability to invite young people
去培养对自己是谁以及未来方向的认知。我会提名4H作为一个做得很好的项目。具体来说，那些告诉我“我可以学习一些世界上尚无人知晓的知识”的机会，对吧？或者我可以学习一些世界上
to cultivate a sense of who they are and where they're going. And I would nominate for each as one that does this quite well. Specifically, opportunities that told me, I can learn something about the world that the world doesn't yet know, right? Or I can learn something about the world
有些人还不知道的知识。我可以与他们分享这些信息。对于年轻时的我来说，那是一次非常重要的经历。我认为从那里开始，关于我们是谁的问题，或者身份认同的问题，是非常重要的，特别是在形成期，去弄清楚：我是谁？我能扮演什么角色？一旦我们解决了我们是谁的问题，我们可能会开始思考：我将成为谁？我正朝着什么方向前进？我认为在那里我们看到了
that some people in the world don't yet know. And I can share that information with them. And that was a really important experience for me as a young person. And I think from there, questions of who we are, or questions of identity, are really important, especially informative years, of figuring out, who am I? What role can I play? And once we've grappled with questions of who we are, we might begin to wonder, where, who am I going to be? What direction am I heading in? And I think there we see that
我将成为谁，我正朝着什么方向前进？我认为在那里我们看到了身份认同与目标之间的联系非常重要，因为如果我们问某人：“你的目标是什么？”那么这句话中的“你”或“你的”要求他们知道自己是谁。所以我认为我们可能会开始将身份认同视为一种自我理解的基础层，当你具备了身份认同感时，你才有可能弄清楚并培养你的目标感。所以你有时会反感人们应该“寻找”目标或“发现”目标的建议，你更倾向于人们将目标视为
going to be what direction am I heading in? And I think there we see that the link between identity and purpose is really important because if we were to ask somebody, well, what is your purpose? Well, the you or the you're in that sentence requires that they know who they are. And so I think we think we might start to think of identity as sort of a foundational layer of self understanding that when you are equipped with to think of identity as sort of a foundational layer of self-understanding that when you are equipped with a sense of identity, you might stand a chance at figuring out and cultivating your sense of purpose. So you sometimes, chief, at the suggestion that people should find their purpose or discover their purpose, you would prefer that people think about purpose
一种需要被培养的东西。我当然忍不住看到了其中的农业隐喻，即某种耕作在起作用。但你能谈谈这个观点吗：目标可能不是躺在地上等着我们去捡的东西，而是真正需要我们与土壤互动（如果你愿意这么说的话）来耕耘的东西？是的，没错。所以我怀疑你可以离开4H，但4H永远不会真正离开你，因为我确实是这样想的，你知道，有一种广泛的理解，甚至是一种处方，认为你可以“找到”目标。事实上，你应该走向世界去
as something to be cultivated. I can't help but of course see the farming metaphor there of sort of cultivation at work. But can you talk about that idea that purpose might not be something that's lying in the ground for us to pick up, but something that really might require our engagement with the soil if you will to cultivate it? Yeah, that's right. So I suspect you can leave for age, but for age will never really leave you, because I do think of it in those terms is, you know, there's a kind of broad understanding and even prescription that you can find purpose. And in fact, you should go out into the world and
找到目标。我只是没看到支持“目标可以被找到”这一观点的证据。我确实理解为什么我们可能会得出“我可以走向世界去找到这个东西”的理解。如果我只是有合适的手电筒，如果你告诉我往哪里看，但我不认为事情真的是这样运作的。目标的获取似乎源于至少三种路径之一。目标可能源于对某个主题或机会的渐进、持续的参与。有点像爱好。每当我有空闲时间，我发现自己都在反复追求某件事。
find purpose. I just don't see the evidence behind the idea that purpose can be found. I do understand why we might arrive at an understanding that I can go out into the world and find this thing. If I just had the right flashlight, if you tell me where to look, but I don't think that's actually how it works. Purpose acquisition seems to arrive off of at least one of three pathways. Purpose might be born out of a gradual, sustained attempt to engage with some topic or opportunity. Kind of like a hobby. Whenever I have downtime, I find myself pursuing something over and over.
随着时间的推移，我开始想：嘿，这是我正在走的路径吗？这是我的目标吗？每当我有时间，我就会回到同一件事上。我通过渐进的探索和培养，最终找到了目标。或者我们可能通过反应性路径到达，生活中发生了一些事情。我家里有人生病了。这不一定是负面的，但在这种情况下，
And over time, I start to think, hey, is this a pathway that I'm on? Is this my purpose? Whenever I have time, I keep going back to the same thing. I sort of arrive at purpose by gradual exploration and cultivation. Or we might arrive at through reactive pathways, something happened in life. Someone in my family fell ill. And it need not be negative, but in instances like that,
目标可能会召唤我。你可能会想：这件事发生了。现在我确切地知道了人生的方向。这两种路径（主动和反应性）有趣的地方在于，这些人可能感到同样有目标感，但其中一种对它的来源有清晰的认识，即反应性路径。
purpose may sort of call me into it. You might think, this thing happened. And now I know exactly the direction of my life. What's interesting about those two pathways, proactive and reactive is, those individuals may feel equally purposeful, but one has clarity about where it came from, the reactive pathway.
他们确切地知道它来自哪里，而主动路径可能无法识别它真正开始的时间。它就像滚雪球。我随着时间的推移不断推动它。第三种路径可能是社会学习路径。有些人感到人生有深刻的目标感，但他们认为是从其他人那里学到了这个目标。
They know exactly where that was from, whereas the proactive pathway might fail to recognize when that really began. It was like a snowball. I kept pushing over time. A third pathway might be the social learning pathway. There are some individuals who feel a profound sense of purpose in life, but they nominate learning about that purpose from other people.
所以他们观察了环境中的某个人培养他们的目标感。现在，你可能不会感受到他们所感受到的同样的感觉，但这可能表明你近距离观察到了它是什么样子的。你看到了早上醒来并真正去追求它是什么样子的。总结一下，托尼和其他研究人员确定了通往目标的三个不同路径。在第一种路径中，当我们追求激情或爱好时，目标会逐渐向我们走来。它会像滚下山的雪球一样变得更大并获得动力。另一种路径是对重大生活事件的反应。家庭成员生病需要我们的帮助。
So they watched somebody in their environment cultivate their sense of purpose. Now, it may not be the case that you feel the same sense that they feel, but it might suggest that you've seen what it looks like up close. You saw what it looks like to wake up in the morning and to really go after it. So to recap, Tony and other researchers have identified three different pathways to purpose. In the first, purpose comes to us gradually as we pursue a passion or a hobby. It can become bigger and gain momentum like a snowball rolling down a hill. Another pathway comes in response to a major life event. A family member gets sick and needs our help.
我们失去了工作，不得不重塑自我。第三种路径是观察另一个有目标的人，并从他们的榜样中汲取灵感。在托尼自己的生活中，他通过将童年经历与成年后的工作联系起来，培养了目标感。我有幸担任教授。我有机会教人们心理学和人类发展。每年春天，我都会教一门大型青少年课程。我走进去，有300张面孔看着我。这非常令人生畏。在过去10年的每一天讲课之前，我在走进教室前的走廊里都会有一段时刻。
We lose a job and have to reinvent ourselves. The third pathway is to observe someone else who has purpose and to draw inspiration from their example. In his own life, Tony has cultivated purpose by linking his childhood experiences with what he does as an adult. I have this wonderful opportunity to serve as a professor. I get to teach people about psychology and human development. And every spring I teach a large adolescence class. I walk in and there's 300 faces looking at me. It's super intimidating. And every day before I've lectured for the past 10 years, I have a moment in the hallway before I walk into my classroom.
我确实会想到我过去向人们展示信息的所有经历，这些经历让我想起了我在爱荷华州布雷默县的4H时光。当我展示土壤时（顺便说一下，我得了红丝带，因为我把它叫作“泥土”而不是“土壤”），那并不是我的目标。那不是我最终成为教授的目标，但我确实有一种方向感，而且
And I really do think about all of the experiences I've had presenting information to people that harken back to my four age days in Bremer County, Iowa. And it wasn't my purpose when presenting about soil, which I got that red ribbon, by the way, because I called it dirt and not soil. That's why lessons weren't. It wasn't my purpose to end up as a professor, but I did have a sense of directionality, and
我确实感觉到我正在学习的课程、我正在经历并随着时间积累的经验，最终会对我有利。到目前为止，事实确实如此。你知道，你刚才说的关于这三种通往目标的路径，你追求一个爱好，最终你意识到这可能是你想做的事情，或者你对生活中发生的事情做出反应，或者你有一个有目标感的榜样，在某种程度上你几乎是通过渗透。你基本上获得了一种被目标感所驱动的感觉。这三种路径让我印象深刻的是，它们不涉及某人坐在沙发上反思他们的目标是什么。这不是一种心理过程，基本上是反复问自己：我应该
I did have a sense that the lessons I was learning and the experiences I was having and collecting over time would bowed well for me in the end. And so far, that's been true. You know, one of the things you said a second ago about these three pathways to purpose, you're pursuing a hobby and eventually you realize this might be something you want to do or you're reacting to something that happens in your life or you have a role model who has a sense of purpose and in some ways you're You know almost through all smoses. You're basically acquiring a feeling of what it's like to be animated by a sense of purpose. What strikes me about all those three pathways is that they do not involve someone sitting down on a couch and ruminating about what their purpose is. It's not sort of a mental process that basically asks the question over and over to yourself, what should
做什么，我的目标是什么？它实际上要活跃得多。它实际上是与世界互动。我想知道你是否能告诉我一个你参与的项目，叫GripTape，它也同样参与其中，你知道，不仅仅是思考目标的培养，而是你实际上是如何去做的，你与年轻人一起工作，问他们实际上想做什么，并在某种程度上为他们提供脚手架。告诉我GripTape以及它与你所学到的关于目标的联系。GripTape是一个让年轻人引导自己学习的精彩项目。GripTape的体验始于询问年轻人：你想学什么？这可以包括从制造自行车到我想学习编程，我想
I be doing, what is my purpose? It's actually much more active. It's actually engaged with the world. I'm wondering if you can tell me about a project that you're involved in called GripTape that is also similarly engaged with, you know, not just thinking about the development of purpose, but how you actually go about it, you work with you that ask them what they actually want to do, and in some ways puts scaffolding under them. Tell me about GripTape and its connections with what you have learned about purpose. GripTape is a wonderful program for young people to guide their own learning. The Grip tape experience begins by asking young people, what is it that you want to learn? This can range from things like building bicycles, it can be, I want to learn how to code, I
创业。内容并不重要。在10周的时间里，他们参与一项学习挑战，他们走向世界，以他们想要学习的精神获取他们需要的信息。现在，关于这个项目的一点是，当你被选中进入GripTape项目时，你会得到一个冠军，一个将和你一起学习的成年冠军。这个项目的美妙之处在于，这些冠军不能在年轻人想要学习的事情上拥有专业知识。我们通常认为导师和冠军是拥有专业知识的人。
want to start a business. It doesn't matter, the content. And for 10 weeks, they engage in a learning challenge in which they go out into the world and gain the information that they need in the spirit of what they want to learn. Now, a couple of features about this is when you are selected into the GRIPTATE program is you're given a champion, an adult champion who's going to learn along with you. And the beauty of the program is these champions cannot have an expertise in the thing that the young person wants to learn. We typically think of mentors and champions as people who do have an expertise.
但通过不拥有专业知识，这严重限制了可以担任冠军的人数。GripTape所做的是邀请年轻人与一个专注的听众一起学习。有一个成年人会定期与他们核对并询问：我们这周学到了什么？你做了什么？你正在分享这些信息，我和一群合作者正在与GripTape项目合作研究这个过程。引导自己的学习如何帮助年轻人培养人生目标感、好奇心、贡献感和幸福感。GripTape项目挑战了“追求目标只属于富人和关系广泛的人，只属于常春藤盟校学生”的观点。它表明培养一种
But that severely restricts the number of people who can serve as a champion by not having an expertise. Grip tape, what they've done, is invited young people to learn with a captive audience. There's an adult who checks in with them routinely and asks, what do we learn this week? What did you do? And you're sharing that information out and a group of collaborators and I are partnering with the GRIPTATE program to study this process. How does directing your own learning, help young people cultivate a sense of purpose in life, curiosity, contribution and well-being. The Grip Day program challenges the idea that seeking purpose is only for the wealthy and well-connected, for students at Ivy League schools. It suggests that cultivating a sense
目标感对于缺乏机会的人来说更为重要。托尼是说唱歌手肯德里克·拉马尔及其歌曲《Good Kid》的粉丝。这首歌是关于在艰难环境中成长并发现选择有限。我是肯德里克·拉马尔的超级粉丝。我要向肯德里克致敬。这首歌很精彩。它邀请人们思考在一个空间里成长、追求目标的选项特别有限的年轻人是什么样的。这让这个年轻人有什么真正的选择？所以当像我这样的人在周围说：“嘿，让我们培养目标吧”，对吧？好吧，我们必须注意，有些人
of purpose is even more important for people who lack opportunities. Tony is a fan of the rapper Kendrick Lamar and his song Good Kid. It's about growing up in top circumstances and finding your options are limited. I'm a huge Kendrick Lamar fan. I'll just shout out to Kendrick. And this song is brilliant. It's an invitation to consider what it's like to be a young person growing up in a space where the options to cultivate your purpose are especially limited And what real choices is that allow this young person. So when people like me are hanging around saying, hey, let's cultivate purpose, right? Well, we have to be mindful that some individuals
生活在空间中，或者发现自己处于空间中，在那里真正思考可能自我清单的机会可能非常有限。我认为这只是一个敏锐的提醒，我们所有人都与他人的环境有关。我们在他人的目标发展中都扮演着角色。这是为了痛苦而种植糖果，我们能生活在同一个社会吗？这让我的大脑非常紧张。你雇我作为……托尼还引用了宇航员梅·杰米森的话。
are living in spaces or find themselves in spaces where the opportunities to really think through the menu of possible selves may be quite constrained. I think it's just a keen reminder that we all are implicated in everybody else's environment. We all play a role in other people's purpose development. It's grown candy for pain, can we live in the same society? It's entirely stressful upon my brain. You hired me as a... Tony also cites the astronaut, Mae Jemisin.
在弗吉尼亚大学的一次演讲中，梅·杰米森谈到了为什么人类即使在自己的生活被日常问题困扰时，也会梦想星空。在这个片段中，她引用了一个问题，这个问题是问一位正在帮助在南非建造望远镜的科学家的。人们问他：当南非有各种问题和贫困时，为什么要那样做？他说因为人们有梦想。梦想并不都围绕着食物。他说，即使是一个睡在泥屋地板上
In a speech at the University of Virginia, Mae Jemisin talked about why humans dream about the stars, even when their own lives are besieged by everyday problems. In this clip, she cited a question posed to a scientist who was helping to build a telescope in South Africa. That people asked him, why would South Africa do that? When it has issues and problems and poverty, he said because people have dreams. And dreams don't all revolve around just food. He said, even a person sleeping on a floor in a mud hut
连毯子都没有的人，也会梦想比自己更伟大的事物，而我们的梦想就是我们的希望。这就是我们前进的方向。梅·杰米森博士，第一位进入太空的黑人女性，是一个非常鼓舞人心的人。她的抱负、她的目标是前往最近的恒星，并真正考虑需要什么才能做到这一点。去说我们应该忙于建造什么样的技术，需要什么样的活动、自我理解来让我们建造那种技术、那种社会、
without a blanket, dreams of things bigger than they are, and that our dreams are our hopes. That's where we move. Dr. Mae Jemisin, the first black woman in space, is a very inspirational person. Her aspiration, her purpose is to travel to the nearest star and to really consider what it would take to do that. To say what kinds of technologies should we get busy building, what kinds of activities, self-understandings are needed for us to build the kinds of technologies, the kinds of societies,
那种工作组关系，使我们能够成功地完成这段旅程。我们目前没有那种推进技术可以到达那里，至少不是完整地到达，但当你坐下来思考她的想法时，你会意识到这是一种诡计。它实际上是让我们思考我们自己，以及我们需要做什么来解决我们当前的挑战。但那种明确目标的天才之处在于，它确实邀请我们思考所有我们需要做的事情
the kinds of working group relationships that would allow us to successfully make this journey. We don't currently have the kinds of propulsion technology to get there, not in one piece at least, but when you sit with her ideas, you realize that it's sort of a trick. It's really getting us to think about ourselves and what we need to do to work through our current challenges. But the genius of that articulated purpose is that it really invites us to think about all the things
作为个人、集体、社区，从艺术到科学，以完成那次旅行。所以这是一个关于目标的深刻隐喻。它是在和我们玩一个把戏，让我们向内看。通过谈论最近的恒星和我们应该准备的旅程，我们在此时此地所做的事情可能是其中最重要的一部分。安东尼·巴罗是康奈尔大学的心理学家。他与帕特里克·黑尔一起，是《跨生命周期的目标生活生态学》一书的编辑。托尼，谢谢你
we need to do as individuals, as collective, as communities, from the arts to the sciences to survive that trip. And so it's a profound metaphor for purpose. It's sort of playing a trick on us to look inward. By talking about the nearest star and the journey that we should be preparing for, it's what we would do in the here and now that may be the most important part of that. Anthony Barrow is a psychologist at Cornell University. Along with Patrick Hale, he's the editor of the book, The Ecology of Purposeful Living Across the Lifespan. Tony, thank you
今天参加Hidden Brain。非常感谢邀请我。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、克里斯汀·王、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是莉莉·珀西。莉莉是播客和广播节目《On Being》的前执行制片人。自从我们成立制作公司以来，莉莉在广泛的运营和政策问题上为我们提供了建议。我们非常感谢她慷慨地分享她的时间和智慧。
for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Lily Percy. Lily is the former executive producer of the podcast and radio show On Being. Since we launched our production company, Lily has given us advice on a broad range of operational and policy issues. We're so grateful for her generosity in sharing her time and wisdom.
如果你喜欢这一集，请想几个可能也会喜欢它的朋友。告诉他们这一集，并告诉他们我们的节目。如果你是播客新手，教他们如何关注我们，或者告诉他们让智能音箱播放Hidden Brain。下周在我们的YouTube系列节目中，我们将审视情绪淹没我们、我们变得对自己感到陌生的时刻。我当时正在告诉我的朋友这件事，我说：“我不认识那个女孩。就像我不认识她一样。”
If you like this episode, please think of a few friends who might like it too. Tell them about this episode and tell them about our show. If you are new to podcasting, show them how to follow us or tell them to ask their smart speaker to play Hidden Brain. Next week in our YouTube.O series, we look at moments when emotions overwhelm us and we become strangers to ourselves. I was telling my friend about this and I'm like, I don't know that girl. Like I don't know her.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。目前还没有这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是Shankar Vedantam。下周见。目前本集还没有评论。点击逐字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。